Why did Allah only reveal the Quran and
promise to preserve it
uh 1400 years ago? Uh why didn't why
didn't Allah preserve the religious
teachings that came purely from from
Allah in earlier times? Thank you.
>> The asked a very good question, very
logical question. He's asking
why did Allah reveal the Quran 1400
years ago?
He should have revealed it first.
If he revealed only Quran from day one,
then we wouldn't have all these
religions. Correct? If you have revealed
Quran first, why Torah, Injil, Zabur,
why not Quran directly? Part of his
question. Second part is why didn't he
preserve the previous scriptures?
Correct. Yes,
>> two questions I'm giving I'm making my
question more difficult. Correct.
>> Okay.
>> I'm saying that why if you want he could
have revealed the Quran first only.
Correct. Then no problem only. And why
didn't he preserve the previous main
question is why didn't Allah preserve
the previous question previous
scriptures and then I'm making my
question more difficult.
Number one, all the previous scriptures
that came, Allah says in the Quran in
surah ro 13 verse number 38
that Allah says
That means in every age Allah has sent a
book by name only four are mentioned in
the Quran. The Torah, the Zabur, the
Injil and the Quran. Torah is the
revelation which was given to Moses
peace be upon him. Zabur is the
revelation which was given to David
peace be upon him. And injil is the wahi
the revelation which was given to Jesus
peace be upon him. And Quran is the last
and final revelation which was revealed
to the last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him.
By name only four are mentioned. But
there are many other revelations. For
example, fool Ibrahim. Many many.
But all the revelations that came before
the Quran, they were meant only for a
particular time period and was meant to
be followed only by a particular group
of people.
For example, Torah was revealed only to
the Jews.
Injil was only revealed to the Jews.
Quran says that Bible says that Quran
says
that Isaam was only sent for the Ban
Israel in surah surah Imran 3:49 that we
sent we appointed Isa Alisam Jesus
Christ peace be upon him as a messenger
to Ban Israel. It's mentioned in surah
chapter number 61 verse number 6. Isa
Alisam says Jesus Christ peace be upon
him the son of Mary says to all children
of Israel I have come to give you glad
tidings of the messenger that came
before me and of a messenger to come
whose name shall be Ahmed Imam
Jesus Christ peace be upon him says in
the gospel of Matthew chapter number 10
verse number 5 and 6 go ye not into the
way of the Gentiles he's telling his
apostles he's telling his disciples Go
ye not into the way of the Gentiles.
Gentiles are the non-Jews, the
Christians, the Hindus, the Muslims. Go
ye not in the way of the Gentiles, but
rather go to the lost sheep of Israel.
So Jesus Christ, peace be upon him, is
telling his disciples, don't go to
preach the non-Jews.
Only preach the lost sheep of Israel.
Jesus Christ says peace be upon him
gospel of Matthew chapter number 15
verse number 24 I have not been sent but
to the lost sheep of the house of
Israel. So all the messengers that came
before prophet Muhammad was sent peace
be upon him only for their people and
the message was meant for a particular
time period till the next message came.
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam has
mentioned in say Bkari volume number one
had number 429 all the messengers that
came before me was sent only for their
people but I have been sent for the
whole of humanity now because prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him was the last
and final messenger as was mentioned in
surah Azab chapter 33 verse number 40
that Muhammad peace be upon him is not
the father of any of you men but he's a
messenger of Allah. He's the seed of the
prophet. Allah is all knowing full of
knowledge. Now because prophet Muhammad
the last time final messenger he was not
sent only for the Muslims or the Arabs.
Allah says in the Quran in surah amyia
chapter number 21 verse number 107
that we have sent thee not but as a
mercy to all the creatures as a mercy to
all the human beings as a mercy to all
the worlds. Allah repeats the message in
surah fat chapter number 35 verse number
28. Allah says
that we have sent thee not but as a
universal messenger giving glad tiding
and warning them against sin but yet
most of the human being don't know now
because Quran is the last and final re
revelation. It was not sent only for the
Muslims or the Arabs. It was sent for
the whole of humanity. This is mentioned
in surah Ibrahim chapter 14 verse number
one in Surah Ibrahim 14 verse number 52
in surah bakra chapter 2 verse number
185 and it's mentioned in surah a
chapter 39 verse number 41 that Quran is
sent for all of humanity.
So because all the other scriptures have
not been meant for eternity, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala did not think it fit
to preserve.
Correct? If it not the message is not
supposed to be valid, what is the
requirement of preserving it? So when
people change the message, Allah sent a
new message and a new messenger. But
because Quran is the last and final
message meant for the whole humanity.
Allah says in surah hij ch ch ch ch ch
ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch
ch ch ch number number 15 verse number
N, we have revealed the Quran and we
shall guard it from corruption.
So this is your reply to your question
that Allah did not preserve. We know by
name four revelation three that came
before the Quran but there were many
other but because they were only time
bound and the message wasn't meant for
eternity Allah didn't think it fit now
coming to the question which I myself
posed then why didn't Allah revealed the
Quran first
if Allah would have revealed the Quran
only first and no other revelation
everyone would have been same but reply
to this is that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is the creator of the human
beings He knows as human very well.
The reply is given in the Bible
in the gospel of John chapter number 16
verse number 12 to 14. Jesus Christ
peace be upon him says I have many
things to say unto you but ye cannot
bear them now for he when the spirit of
truth shall come he shall guide you onto
all truth. He shall not speak of
himself. All that he shall speak he
shall glorify because Jesus Christ knew
the message peace be upon him but he
knew that people could not understand
it. So almighty God knew that the human
beings have not developed so well to
grasp the message of the Quran. That the
reason he didn't reveal it 5,000 years
back or 4,000 years back or 3,000 years
back.
1,400 years ago, Allah who is our
creator, almighty God said, "Okay, now
human beings can grasp the final
revelation."
Who said this? Jesus Christ peace be
upon him in the Bible gospel of John
chapter number 16 verse number 12 to 14.
Jesus Christ said, "I have many things
to say unto you, but he cannot bear them
now." Same thing the other messenger
said. Same thing in the Buddhist
scripture. Buddha said, same thing
Zarashtra said any messenger, another
messenger is going to come. Same thing
Moses said in the gospel of in the book
of Deuteronomy chapter number 18 verse
number 18. So Allah knew that human
being could not absorb it could not
understand it. Difficult to implement
1400 years ago Allah said okay now is
the time that human beings can absorb
the message. So he revealed the message
and he said he will guard it from
corruption. That is the reason today
irrespective whether you're staying in
Indonesia or Malaysia or USA or UK or
Singapore or Saudi Arabia or India or
Pakistan you have to follow the last and
final messenger prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him and last and final message
the Quran.
Hope that answers the question brother.
>> Can we have the last question brother?
Brother, do you have any do you agree
with my answer?
>> Uh yes, thank you for your answer.
>> Okay, you can ask your third question,
brother.
>> So the last question is what do you
think if someone doesn't want to accept
Islam because they have been bullied
by Muslims and become Islamophobic? Uh
the example is uh my sister who told
>> sorry sorry whether you said that
because they have been bullied by
Muslims and after that I didn't hear
>> uh Islamophobic and become Islamophobic.
>> Islamophobic. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh the example is my sister uh who told
uh non-Muslim blood is halal by her
Islam religion subjects teacher.
>> Sorry. Non-Muslim blood is haram.
>> Yeah. Non-Muslim blood is halal.
>> Yes.
>> She think that the Muslims can kill the
non-Muslims.
>> Uh yes. Uh it it was said uh by her uh
Islam religion subjects teacher. The
brother asked the question what if
someone has been bullied by some Muslims
and that Muslim tells a non-Muslim that
is a sister that the blood of non-Muslim
is halal
and a Muslim can kill a non-Muslim. So
what is the reply? Number one,
the Muslim who bullied the non-Muslim
will be punished.
If it was an Islamic country, Islamic
state of law, if the religion of Islam
was followed, if that Muslim was taken
to the court of law, he would have been
punished. Do you understand? Now,
the person who bullied your sister, he
is wrong. Number one. But because your
sister got bullied, suppose my teacher
taught me 2 + 2 is equal to 5.
Correct? When I was a kid, I said 2 + 2
is 5. Now when I become an adult and if
I say my teacher said 2 + 2 is equal to
5, therefore 2 + 2 5. Will you forgive
me?
>> No.
>> Okay. As a kid, no problem. Age of
three, four, my teacher told me 2 + 3 is
equal to 5. So I repeated it. Now when I
become adult,
My teacher told me wrong, I can discover
right from wrong. So just because
teacher told me wrong full life I will
not keep on saying 2 plus 2= 5. Correct.
>> Yes.
>> For that few years acceptable that
teacher wrong. God will punish the
teacher if it did purposely. But for me
I have to grow up.
Okay fine. My teacher bullied me. I was
a small kid. I agreed. I made a mistake.
God will forgive me. But now 2 + 2 is
equal to 4. You understand? So someone
tells me that man,
the neighbor,
he is a villain.
He is a murderer. Okay, when I'm a kid,
I agree. But when I grow up and find out
that the man is very good, he's very
loving, he's very generous, he's very
kind, I should not continue having that
same view.
I should change my view. So if your
sister got bullied by a Muslim
and she had Islamophobia, that person
who bullied
>> brother.
>> Yes.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Uh yes.
>> Yes. So if I'm giving the answer, if you
can look at me better.
>> Yes. Sorry.
>> I think you're talking amongst
yourselves. Otherwise, you'll miss the
answer and then you won't know what I
said. You can't do two things together.
100% partly you can do. So if your
sister was bullied by a Muslim who gave
wrong information of Islam, she had
Islamophobia, that Muslim will be
punished.
If not here, Allah will see to him that
he's punished. But your sister, she has
to now know the truth. If she if she's a
kid, she'll be forgiven 5 years, 10
years, okay? But once she becomes an
adult, she's no longer a kid. That time
she has to accept the truth. She cannot
keep on repeating two players equal to
five. My neighbor is not good. If your
neighbor is good is good. You understand
now? So
you should be since you are the brother,
you should guide her and tell her that
whoever was your friend, they told you
wrong things and encourage them like the
lecture I gave today. Correct? The
lecture I gave was Islam's view on
terrorism and jihad
and one verse
which I missed out in my lecture which I
have to mention now. I would like to
thank you for that. That one verse of
the Quran is sufficient to prove that
Muslims are not terrorist. Allah says in
surah Maida chapter number 5 verse
number 32, if anyone any human being
kills any other human being unless it be
for murder or for spreading corruption
in the land it is as though he has
killed the whole of humanity.
Allah says in the Quran in surah Maida
5:32 that if any human being whether
Muslim or non-Muslim kills any other
human being whether Muslim or non-Muslim
kills any other innocent human being
it is as though he has killed the whole
of humanity and the verse continues if
any human being saves any other human
being he saved the whole humanity. So
this verse of the Quran says if any
Muslim kills any innocent non-Muslim
also
it is as though he has killed whole of
humanity. Is it clear?
>> Yes.
>> Quran says if any one human being even a
Muslim kills any other innocent human
being even if it be a non-Muslim it is
as though he has killed the whole of
humanity. And if any human being whether
Muslim or non-Muslim saves any other
human being innocent, it is as though he
has saved the whole nation. So this
verse of the Quran, it doesn't appear
anywhere else in any scripture except
the Quran. No other religion.
It is sufficient to prove that Islam is
against terrorism
and will also remove the misconception
of your sister, the Islamophobia, that
she was told something wrong. Quran is
solid proof
to say that the blood of the non-Muslim
is halal is a fabrication. Okay. If the
non-Muslim comes to attack you
then you can defend no problem. If it's
in the battlefield that's a different
thing if there there's operation but
generally to say this it is totally
wrong. It's again the verse of the Quran
of surah ma 5:32. Hope that answers the
question.
>> Thank you.
Brother, now coming back to my question.
You said you believe there's one God.
You said you believe that Jesus is the
messenger of God. You also believe that
Prophet Muhammad is the messenger of
God. So I asked you the question then
what is stopping you from accepting
Islam?
>> Um maybe because I'm not financially
stable.
Uh so
>> brother does to be a Muslim do you have
to be rich?
>> No.
>> Is there any criteria in the Quran that
you have to be rich to be a Muslim?
Our beloved prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said it is easier for
the poor man to go to Jenna than a rich
man. Do you know that?
>> Yes.
>> Our beloved prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said it is easier for a
poor man to go to Jenna than a rich man.
That means if you're poor, your life,
your test will be easy.
I'll give you a few examples. If you're
rich,
Allah says in the Quran and various
hadith that you have to give zakat
that every rich Muslim who has a saving
of more than nisab level more than 85 g
of gold he or she should give 2.5% of
that saving every lunar year in charity.
If you don't give it's a big sin. But
for the poor man who doesn't have saving
he has to give no charity. So in zakat
he gets 100 out of 100. For the rich man
if he doesn't give he gives zero out of
one. Maybe he'll give half. He'll not
give right. So he get less marks. But
for the poor man who has to give no
zakat he gets 100 out of 100. Do you
understand?
>> Yes.
>> So there are various tests. Even the
poor man has got test. Even the rich man
has got test. But the rich man the test
is difficult. And a beloved prophet
>> Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
you know he said
that
you have to give charity.
So one of the sabas asked
Allah how can we give charity?
So he says that go in the marketplace
and do zikar of Allah
take Allah's name
illallah
and say the talah
it is like distributing gold
in the market. If you praise Allah in
the marketplace loudly, you'll get more
blessing than a rich man distributing
gold. Brother, have you seen any rich
man distributing gold in the
marketplace? Have you seen? Have you
seen? Yes or no?
>> I have also not seen. I have never seen.
Here a prophet says
a poor man who got no wealth if he
praises Allah
and says the talia in the marketplace
Allahbar Allahbarbah
[Music]
he praises Allah says the talah says the
hum the prophet said it is you get more
blessing than a rich man distributing
putting gold. So tell me it's easier for
rich man to go to Jenna or poor man.
>> It's poor.
>> So that's the reason more poor people
accept Islam than rich. You may have
heard the story of Bilar the companion
of the prophet who was a slave black
slave. They tortured him.
They told him say that there is no one
god. He yet said ah. The prophet told if
someone tortures you,
you can even do shik as long as faith
is. He said no. I will yet say all.
Do you understand? Poor man.
He's been promised paradise.
Do you understand?
>> Yes. So
wealth should not be a criteria for you
not to accept Islam.
In fact, if you're poor, every rich
person should give zakat. There are
eight categories. Eight categories in
Surah Taba chapter 9 verse number 61
categories give to the fukkara. If I'm
rich, every year I have to give minimum
2.5% of my wealth, of my savings and
charity to the poor people. Fukar is one
category. Masak is there are many
categories. Eight categories.
So
do you have to pay tax to become a
Muslim?
No.
So why should it prevent that is the
reason there are more poor people who
accept Islam than the rich people? Rich
people. Oh, rich people have to pay tax
or not.
>> Yes.
>> Zakat 2.5%. Yes or no? Yes. So if rich
man says I'm a billionaire if I become a
Muslim I have to pay 2.5% zakat. I'm not
becoming a Muslim. He's a fool.
But some wrong logic but some wrong
logic for why should a poor man feel
afraid.
And mashallah in a country like
Indonesia 87% Muslims
many people all ready to protect you.
Why should you get scared?
What is stopping you brother?
>> Yes, I agree.
>> Uh yes I agree.
>> Mashallah brother I love you.
>> Thank you.
>> I love you and I want you to come to the
state park. So if we agree would you
like to say the shahada?
>> Um sorry can I uh do it off cam?
>> Can you do it
>> off off camera?
>> No problem. It's not a fur. It's not a
fur to say in public.
>> Thank you. As long as you say in your
heart between you and Allah it is
sufficient. So I congratulate you
brother and understood that you are
wearing the mask not for corona.
Maybe you were not you didn't want to
reveal and that's perfectly fine. If you
want to hide your identity because you
feel someone may harm you etc. It's
perfectly accepted in Islam. You don't
have to say it in public. As long as you
got the message I'm happy I delivered
the message to you. May Allah inshallah
guide you more. May Allah give you the
best in this world. May Allah grant you
Jenna and may Allah help you others to
>> get you closer. May you help others to
come close to Islam. Amen.
>> If you want to meet me after the talk in
the green room, you're most welcome.
Even if you don't want to meet me, no
problem. It's not necessary you have to
meet Dr. Zakai to be a Muslim. As long
as you accept, may Allah reward you.
Thank you, brother.
Mashallah.